ich habe spaß es ist häufig anlass auf
wenn nicht im paradies blitze das ist
ein 1 1 ein magisches licht wenn du es
anstellen wenn das angriffs kräftig auf
ich hinterlasse über geil da muss man
immer mit lachen die ganzen leute meinen
dass auch in kommentaren
aber wenn ich jetzt lache dass meine
stimme glaube ich komplett weg deswegen
wollte ich auch mehrere leute damit ich
nicht ganz so viel quatschen muss ja
klar ich mache wieder gleichauf
diamanten counter geld bei wievielen
aktuell grad stehen momentan auf null
ich habe übrigens eine glücks spitzhacke
mit glück 3 drauf das heißt es aus einem
jemand so locker mal so 3ds kommt
restaurants pazifische platte wo du
überall durchgucken kann dieses genau
damit kann ich sie dann abbauen
er kann zur erde herrschen das kann ich
theoretisch auch machen ja wenn ich das
ich kandidiere ich kann die mit gottes
zu uns austauschen
brauche ich erstmal ich sollte mir
vielleicht erstmal jede farbe machen
damit ich oder weiß dass auch dies wäre
ich könnte passieren laufen dass er
diese mabel brig wand gehe um einen
zauberstab und verwandelt den marken den
erde
nacheinander wird es aber eine
regelverletzung ist es ein paar folgen
gefasst ich weiß ich bin doch einfach
ein bisschen nehmen zu die den lauf und
alles in luft springen wie hättest du so
ich brauche etwas zu machen und ich bin
tot ich ändern und spinnen und da und
alle sehen darfst nicht angucken
ja aber ich glaube der hat sich schon
auf lack und jetzt bin ich mit der erde
gab grube so tief dass sich schon
bestens anguckt mein ziel ist wirklich
einfach dass ich 100 folgen sagen kann
hey ich habe mich hier bis zum bedrock
runter geehrt
die folge müssen
in der neuen folge ach so das heißt du
schneidest macht keine begrüßung
abschied und so macht einfach viel am
ende durch neben blabla ok dann ich
mache mal begrüßen da schieben das heißt
hier kommt eine verabschiedung und dann
sehen uns nächste folge sorgt dann kann
ich mich mal starten
321 ich jetzt so hallo an alle zum
nächsten folge des mega projekts
zusammen mit luca und themes prime games
wir sind immer noch live mit dabei wie
ich glaube es ist passiert so einfach am
meisten oder ja leider immer alles
stimmt doch nicht braucht viel marvel
ich kann dir was mitbringen und ganz
viel springt pulver und ganz viel sand
gefunden und charts alles gibt es viele
ärzte die einfach genauso aussehen wie
diamant ihren ich muss gleichzeitig auch
gefunden und zwar schon 19 stück silver
es selber nicht weiß es nicht also nicht
so wirklich glauben braucht man gleich
später ordentlich aber ich brauche
einfach diamanten
ich möchte erstmal mein haus jetzt bauen
so ein bisschen und danach genau das
jetzt mit diamanten zuerst macht luca
ich brauche die ganze sache damit ich
hier erde abbauen kann und die man
später auf ganz gut weil du so willst
dass erstens die schaufel machen zum er
davon leben habe ich ja schon jetzt ach
du hast mit der schaufel gemacht ja
nicht dein ernst lemmer westen diamonds
ohne schaufel oder eine hohe damit
nachher schon gar nicht aber einer
schaufel ja ich weiß eigentlich kannst
auch gerne bei mir noch die schaufel
verzaubern damit dann übelste speech ist
weil man das aus
clever skeleton es hilft die ganze zeit
über die bank darüber wussten das kann
ich jetzt seit dem ich krank bin also
schon immer manches wissen ist gesetzt
ich glaube schwierigkeitsstufen normal
und die ki wo die reformen gewissen
update in kandhamal verbesserung ja das
regt mich richtig auf das wir auch
normal sind da kann ich gar keinen hehl
ich bin normal ist doch ok team ob sie
noch voll putzig die machen doch kaum
was sagst du mit 1000 v bestehen
ich meine was nachkommt dann wird
gegrillt soft 10.000 volt golfelite ich
bin so was habe ich alles ich könnte ein
spinner essen aber dafür hat es gedauert
so weit zu kommen
das ist ja nicht mal so von heute auf
morgen passiert ressourcen sammeln
okay von heute auf übermorgen vor einer
woche gekommen bist du jetzt erst so
dass einfach alles ja durch gesucht wird
ein bisschen aber da war das bei einem
42 40 15 durch 14 sind einfach zehn
stunden zehn stück auf dem schlauch noch
ich habe hier gefunden momente das
ergebnis wird bei mir einfach so sein
dass ich dann eine erdschicht gemacht
habe nein ich hab ich grad so erschreckt
weil an den rhein und einfach
produktiven stück toast
so jetzt geht man der die account hoch
also ich mach mal sowie account oder
skat steht geld zu sparen wird das
ähnlich
ja ja ich habe zwei sechs und fünfzehn
oben in der tat wenig was genau will ich
hab aus passau
ich bin immer noch bei mir im bergbau
außerdem würde ich damit gegen eine
regel verletzt und im knast schmoren das
wäre noch langweiliger als er wohl das
gar nicht langweilig alles ist möglich
auch anhand übrigens nicht das ist ja so
die selbstironie ganzen story die ja so
der konnte auf 10 c diamanten eben
gerade gefunden ich lasse gefunden und
wie viel hast du dir da durch die durch
dieses glück dings geholt ich glaub ich
hab viel gefunden und aus vier ärzten
wurden zehn gas aus einem märz also eben
gerade schnell fiel das haus geführt
jedoch eine spitzhacke mit wenn man
jetzt keine glücksritter guard und diese
selbst spitze könnte man das auch mit
dem generator meta dann die als
verdoppelt aber dann kriegst doppel
heraus die freezers doppelbetten doppelt
einmal kein glücksspiel sagt ja ich habe
ein paar blätter ich ja vortage macht
den aber auch ich habe drei stacks
oxidieren plötzlich mein portal glaube
ich durch mein portal soll durch ein
bisschen kloster wohlig mussten
begleiten weil er angst hatte steht und
ich konnte mit dem zauberstab und dem
abbau zauberstab ja schön an der decke
dann die erz abbauen werden die von dir
dann oft umgezogen die ärzte die fand
einfach nur unter seien vom abbau es
gibt doch auch in so einem brustpanzer
die aber ein rucksack ist oder den
rucksack aus
so ich brauche auf jeden fall noch mal
mehr erde wird sagen locker nochmal mit
ja wirklich wieder los brauchen wir
nicht was zu mampfen jetzt das wird
körper sich das kämpfen machen
also ich kann mir anbieten auf einem
getreidefeld das getreide ab zählten
aber nur das getreide ich das flachs und
dann kannst du wenn du dieses wieder neu
setzt ist alles wunderbar da kannst du
behalten
kein problem
ich sollte wieder ich hatte allerdings
beim jo gegen derweil nein bei steffen
als gesehen dass vorschlagen oder was ja
auch eine ganz gute idee fand mit
minecraft links ist die beide die
rüstung und ein schwert bekommt dann
gegeneinander patches da hätte ich bin
schlecht steffens noch schlechter das
wäre eben eine ganz schwere entscheidung
doch bestimmt 13 die u17 diamanten ja
der fdp warnten 19 724 klebe jetzt
erstmal bis 25
ein bisschen bisschen diamanten bakr
getreide natürlich so die polizei
das war also du bist total nett ja also
ich würd auch nichts dagegen sagen wenn
du dir über allerdings was so dass es
magisches licht sind zwei kleine länder
gut gemacht haben dann kann es jetzt
einfach aufsammeln wieder hinsetzen
jetzt sagen wieder hinsetzen also so 1
kanzlers da machen mir einen
regelverstoß luca filippi jetzt war aus
versehen
ich habe es auch nicht gemacht als er
wollte mal ausprobieren aufgemacht das
kaputt weizen arbeiten daher eine wende
wenn das legitimiert ist alles in
ordnung
na ja das passt schon die kamera wieder
hinsetzen kaputt gemacht anfang gleich
not das park hat bestimmt welche helm
auf der ihm immer neues essen gibt von
daher kenne ich hab noch immer vom ein
jetpack auflädt
ich kann noch werden fliegen aufladen
ich kann auch wenn ich jetzt eine höhle
bin
das klingt das nicht mehr ist nicht mehr
auf den schaden nicht aber ist das jetzt
so dass es sich richtig lohnt beim
fliegen also dass du gar nicht öffnen
das nenne ich muss schon noch auf boden
aber das kannst du einstellung kanzian
stärkeren noch nehmen ich habe nur den
ganz einfachen helm es gibt ja noch die
nächste stufe den mittleren den jetzt
materialien hole ich hab mir nochmal
noch mal was hast du gesagt ich geh
jetzt lecker aber nur damit ich die welt
so für ein level aber das ist okay das
voll die dänen die stelle wo man das ist
echt dämlich sieht aus wie im gleichen
alter was wird hierfür für zeug rum nach
assen die höhe
dann kann es läuft ihr habt das das
fliegt das läuft ich habe viel spaß es
ist klar was aufwändig paradies blitze
das ist ein 1 1 ein magisches licht wenn
du es anstelle des angriffs kräftig auf
ich weiß nicht die kunden haben richtig
verdient ich fordere ich habe durch das
zaubern solisten die magie in der welt
sozusagen erweckt jetzt kommen da aus zu
klein dimensionierten ich gerne mal
solche bis aus im bus raus ich komme
jedoch eine server darauf dass
communication terror jetzt bin ich drauf
oder euch wieder chance diesen fall
putzig machen expedia.de herausgefallen
begeistert sind ist einfach ins portal
ich war einfach kurz davor wieder
rauszukommen
wenn ich richtig gefeiert ja diese
diesen fall nicht ich eigentlich
reichlich stauraum stadt hat dann kann
man die einfach töten wenn man keiner
dann nicht weil die haben halte ich
immer sehr fair nicht die könnten luca
leuchten ja gut ich bin schuldig hut
gezaubert ist gut die kollegen wir
übrigens thema im haus ist immer wird es
also nicht wundern wenn öfters mal so
viel herauskommen
die bände dimension sogar den kanzler
nur sehen wenn mal die brille hat die
ich habe meine zeit später wenn ich
wieder raus mit seiner brille ja ich
hab's gesehen und dann theoretisch auch
ein kann sich sehen lassen den zauber
kessel katrin ist insoweit ein element
das eine bessere sicht auf die magie
dieser welt woche höher versuche jedes
benutzen sie interessant ist dann
erzähle ich lieber davon viel jemand
nicht schon gefunden
ich versuche so ein bisschen interessant
zu gestalten weil ansonsten lässt
langweiliges erklären wie er das werk
oder hat angehalten ist ja auch du deine
leute bei mir geht es gerade richtig ab
wir finden gerade so viele ärzte und
alle ich glaube einfach denn wenn ich
mag einfach mal eine wende in der
viertelstunde sein inventar 11 geöffnet
lassen würde dann wenn er schon so viele
leute mit zufriedene das wäre
unglaublich
wenn sich das einfach mal angucken
könnte oder dass partner
es gibt der benutzten gar nicht mal die
ganzen platz von der diamant kiste
kräftig aber nicht die amag ist damit
der eine hat er klar
so ich habe zwei diamant ist so alles
aufbauen dass keine mops mehr wie hier
über den rand bei mir rein kommt doch da
könnten doch welche ums bauen und
machtvoll ich das so ja ich habe
übrigens auch ein bisschen mehr inventar
als hier wahrscheinlich weil ich habe
drei rucksäcke auf 15 slots das heißt
ich habe 45 weitere sechs weitere slots
für steine 11 15 mal dass viele steine
vom präsentiert mehrere rucksäcke
aufsetzen
ja ja ich will man kann ja ich hab drei
bergarbeiter rucksäcke einen für
rucksack und ein jäger auf die hast du
musik gerade auf wir mussten ihr habt
nicht angezogen die muslime kann man
nicht auf die kette legen so kann die
ganze inventar und rechtsklick machen
genau da hast du das da drin
ich habe jetzt ein 540 weitere slots nur
für ärzte so zu sein allerdings ist
wichtig okay leute werde ich mich auch
wie flexible und beschäftigt
dann geht's dir dann auch titel von dem
so ob jeweils park
ja ich versuche halt wie gesagt sehr
interessant zu machen also 133 zwar
gesagt dass du ein toller satz
ich habe vertrauen zwischen und hey es
fängt an zu regnen wo ich genau gerade
in der verzauberung distribution
ausgestatteten bücherregalen 50 als 30
33 käme also höchsten stufe theoretisch
verzaubern wenn ich dieses wenn sie
erlauben würde ich ich könnte dir auch
mehr bücherregal gegeben weil ich habe
keinen versorgungsauftrag ich brauche
also ich dachte ich bin schon alles
fertig keine sorge du darfst ich habe
jetzt nicht so etwas gehen ich habe mir
komm ich hab mal gefragt ob ich euch die
anderen das benutzen lassen soll dann
die in den kommentaren geschrieben 1
faktor das nicht bis schon so netten
vorteil zumal sachen aber du kannst ja
so machen dass wir einfach bezahlen das
denkt verzaubern werden
ich will nicht der verzaubern ich kann
von zauber nicht mal buchstabieren
ja gut ist einfach nur das sei dann kein
schwert aus schaf ist drauf hast mir
schaden und so genossen so vielleicht
nützlich für dich ich kann das auto muss
mit v schreiben dann stimmt sie
verzaubern
so ist jetzt noch wo meine mutter das 3
3 oder 4
das war klar dass er wieder am wenigsten
machen das dachte ich mir bei ghom aber
auch er ist aber der den
machtverhältnisse echten viel also ich
finde auch mal bock als ich mit nichts
gemacht aber wenn ich das so sehe macht
es mir direkt burana realistische
möglichkeit manchmal steigt man sich als
auch die standard sachen fest haus bauen
und so aber ich hab mir gedacht gleich
forschen ich habe noch kein haus aber
gleich erst mal vor schon gleich
vorankommen und darf nicht mehr von wem
von euch erde kleinlich ich gebe zu ich
würde aber gerne habe ich will jetzt
keine farben gehen jetzt denke ich an
ihr luca der leite ich alles hier hat so
viele schulden mit zinsen plan
nee ich liebe alles einfach nur weil ich
gerade eigentlich vermeiden wollte etwas
regnen das nachtlokal schulden 91 blöcke
vom entfernt ja es war keine frage ein
aus dem grundstück ab da hast du die
möglichkeit bergleute zu teleportieren
mit seinem zauberstab